아 저는 이게 좀 오래 역대급 살인
거 같아요 저도 보면서
굉장히 놀랬습니다 이거 매입하신 분은
축하드립니다
[음악]
지금 오늘은
2023년도에
빌사남이 생각하는 가장 매입을 잘한
아이 사례는 진짜 너무 잘 샀다 그런
사례를 제가 이제 금액대별로 좀
소개를 해 드리도록 하겠습니다 어
일단 올해는
작년보다는 이런 좀 괜찮은 매물을 살
수 있는 기회가 그래도 조금 있었던
거 같아요 작년 이맘때 같은 경우에는
그래도 금리가 오르기 전이어서 일단은
돈이 있어도 좀 사기도 어려운
시장이었고
금액 조정도 좀 잘 안 되는
시장이었고 그랬는데 올해 1월이 이제
거래량이 완전 체저였어요 그리고
2월달 좀 후반부부터 좀 거래량이
상승했고 3월달부터 좀 거래량이 좀
상승하긴 했는데 어찌됐든 올해는
그래도 좀
뭔가 기회가 있는 시장이어서 제가
강남 지역 위주로 제가 선배를 좀
해봤습니다 그래서 기대하셔도 좋을 것
같습니다
50억 미만의 제일 잘 샀다라고
생각하는 거는
건물인데 35억에
매입을 했고 대지 평단가루 봤을 때는
7,446만원입니다 대지가 47평이고
연면적 94평
2016년도에 준공한 건물이고 그리고
보증금이 꽤 높게 있었어요 한 21억
정도 설정이 돼 있었고 그래서 여기
자체가 좀 이렇게 오피스 수요가
그래도 좀 꽤 있는
지역이거든요 그리고 금액대가 35억인
것도 굉장히 좀 매력적이었고 그리고
2016년도에 건물이 준공된 것도
되게 좀 매력적인
요소고 근데 이제 엘리베이터가 좀
없었고 그리고 지하가 따로 파져 있진
않았어요 제 개인적인 생각에 만약
이걸 산다라고 하면 일단 엘리베이터
자리를 좀 봤을 것 같고이 주택
부분을 좀 이렇게 근생으로 좀 바꿔서
좀 오피스 좀 작은 통인데 사옥으로
이렇게 임대를 주면은
임대가 되게 잘 되는 곳이기 때문에
전 이거는 좀 35억대
치고는 되게 주 투자를 너무 잘했
생각을 합니다 그리고 두 번째 사례
50억에서 100억 사례를 좀 봤는데
아 저는 이게 좀 오래 역대급 살인
거 같아요 저도 보면서
굉장히 놀랬습니다 일단 위치는 여기
학동력 4번 출구 바로 이면에 제가
제일 좋아하는 도료죠 대로 바로
이면에 12m 도로에
지금요 건물입니다네
신축해야 되는 부지긴 하는데 일단
딱이 모습만 보면
와 이게 뭐 좋은 거야 하실 수도
있는데 일단은 도로 자체가 너무
좋아요네 도로 자체가 너무 좋고
역 바로 앞에 이제
큰 도로변에 끼고 있는 그런 건물이고
그리고요 건물은 무엇보다
준주거지역입니다 준주거지역 지금
준주거지역이면 저희가 건폐율 60%의
최대 400%까지
적용을 받는데 아무래도 여기가
400% 다 적용 다 받을지 한번
체크는 해 봐야 될 것 같아요 여기
이제 지구단위 계획으로 되어 있어서
확인은 해 봐야 되는데
땅의 가치가 되게 높은 지역입니다
유튜브에서 한 번도 이런 말을 한
적은 없지만
정말 사체를 끌어다가 사야
될 만한 그런 건물이었던 것 같습니다
그래서 저도이 사례를 보면서
굉장히 좀 놀랬습니다 저희가
웬만한 빌딩 데이터는 다 가지고
있거든요 그리고 실제로 매물도 한
시장이 나와 있는 거 그래도 한 8
90%는 저희가 가지고 있는데 이
사례는 저희도 없었어요
시장에 나와 있지 않았던 매물이었던
것 같습니다 뭐 등기사항 정부
증명서를 떼서 보니까 그 전에
매도인분이
1972년도에 매입을 했더라고요
그래서 간혹가다 이런 매물들이 나와요
강남 처음 개발할 때부터 가지고
계셨던 그 어르신 분들이
갑자기 던지는 매물들이 나오거든요
그래서
약간 그런
매물이지 않을까 대지가 67평이었고
매매 금액이 무려 50억이었습니다
7,400만원이었고 제가 감히
예상하자면
50% 거의 50% 할인으로 산 거
같아요 너무 잘 샀습니다 그러니까
여기 시세 자체 그리고 이제
준주거지역이 땅에 같이 자체가 그래도
한 1억 중반 정도는 되는데
7,400으로 산 거예요 오늘
말씀드린 사례 중에서 제일 잘 산
살입니다 대출은
40억 정도 받았더라구요 그래서
현금 한 10억 취득세까지 하면은
현금 한 10억 초반으로 매입을
했습니다 이거 매입하신 분은
축하드립니다 이제 100억 건물들을
좀 볼 건데 지금요 건물입니다
요건데 지금 위치가 이제 신사역에서
거리는 굉장히 가깝습니다 그리고
외관을 좀 보면은 지금요 건물이고
저는요 건물이 잘 샀다고 일단
생각하는 이유 중에 하나가 여러분들이
아셔야 될게 지금 뭐 가로수길 쪽이
메인 도로나 이런 데가 좀 임대
상황은 안 좋아요 근데 지금이 위치
같은 경우에는 여기는 신사역
사건이에요 물론 이제 가로수길 상권의
영향을 받긴 하지만 그래서 여러분들이
8번 출구에 내려서 바로 오면은
저녁에 이제 그 먹자상권 밤산권이
많이 활성화되어 있는데이 건물 같은
경우에도 이제 그쪽 상권에 해당되는
곳이에요 그리고요 건물 같은 경우에는
대지가 99평
연면적이 247평입니다
땅 가격만 봤을 때는 한 평당 1억
한 2,800 정도의 매입을 했고
그리고요 건물이 제가 생각하기에
리모델링 하기 너무 좋은 건물이에요
구조도 철근 콘크리트로 되어 있고
지금
엘리베이터가 없어서 임대수익이 안
나오거든요 뭐 엘리베이터랑 리모델링만
하면 너무 괜찮을 만한 건물입니다
용적률이 좀 남아 있어서 한 10평
정도는 좀 늘릴 수 있습니다 그래서
전에 그 저희 김준석 소장님이 좀
검토했던 건데 기존의 화장실 위치에
엘리베이터 신설이 좀 가능합니다
그래서
엘레베이터를 화장실에 넣고 그리고
화장실이 이제 내부에 다 설치하는
방향으로 보통 많이 하거든요 리모델링
이거는 뭐 돼지 평당가도 너무 괜찮고
리모델링 하기 딱 좋은 건물입니다
상권도
워낙 여기가 그래도 좀 괜찮기 때문에
리모델링 하고 나서도 임대도 되게 잘
들어갈 것 같아요
신사역 인근에 있는 건물이고 리모델링
하기 너무 좋은 건물이고 그리고 또
한 가지 사례를 말씀드리면
요것도 오래 산 거 중에 되게 잘
샀어요 여기 위치에 있는데 압구정역
근처에 위치한 건물이고
북향입니다 저희 구독자분들 다
아시겠지만
북향을 사야지 이제 일조권 시간을 좀
덜 받아요 그래서 지금 여기 주택
건물이었고 대지가 141평이었고
매매 금액이 145억이었습니다 그래서
평당 1억 정도의 매각이 됐어요 주변
사례로 봤을 때는 완전 급매였습니다
인근 사례가 그래도 대지 평당가로
봤을 때는 1억 중반 정도 되는데 한
1억원 정도의 매입을 했습니다
물론 신축부지긴 하지만 나중에 지었을
때 여기 그래도 임대수요가 꽤 많은
곳이어서 좀 차익이 많이 날 것으로
예상이 됩니다 그리고 이제 대망의
마지막
피날레를 장식할 제가 좋아하는
건물입니다 청담동에서 그래서이
건물인데 여기가 이제 학동사거리고
여기가 이제 청담사거리입니다 그래서
그 사이에 있는 건물이고 제가 일전에
그 st 송은빌딩 말씀드렸던 적이
있어요 그래서 그 뭐 그 근처에 있는
빌딩이고 지금이 건물입니다 그래서
건물을 더 올릴 수 있는 여기에
노선상업지거든요 그래서
가중평균 했을 때 건물의 가치를 좀
최대한 끌어올릴 수 있는 그런 건물이
보시면 될 것 같습니다
466억 5천만원에
매입을 했습니다 그리고 대지가
178평이고 대지 평당가로 봤을 때는
한 2억 6천 정도 그 도산대로가
보통 한 3억 이상 정도 되거든요 뭐
1월 달이 아무래도 좀 시기가 많이
안 좋다 보니까 되게 저렴한 가격에
매각이 된 거 같습니다 그리고 한
100억 정도 대출 받아서 매입을
했고 그리고 앞서 설명드렸지만 이게
노선상업지다 보니까
용적률을 약 한 470% 정도 받을
수 있습니다
빨간 색깔이 상업지 여기가 이제
3종인데 가중평균 하면 한 470%
정도 적용을 받고 그래서 만약
신축했을 때 저희가 예상 건축기요
그때
짜봤었는데
지하 2층에 지상 12층 정도 올릴
수 있는 뭐 개요를 저희가 받았었고
그 다음에 연면적인
그렇게 만약에 신축을 했을 때 한
1,100평 정도 나오는 그런
땅이었습니다 그래서
도산대로 거래 사례 중에서는
그래도 되게 좀 잘 매입한 사례라고
생각합니다 올해 산 거 중에 원래
여기 자체가 매물이 안 나와요 1년에
뭐 제가 봤을 때는
진짜 많으면 다섯 권 신사역
사거리부터
영동대교 남단부터
진짜 많으면 5건이 정도 거래가
됐는데 올해 사례 중에는 제일
매입 잘한 사례라고 저는 생각합니다요
중에 최고를 뽑자면 아까 말씀드렸던
그 학동역 앞에 있던 그 준주거지를
굉장히 싸게 샀습니다 저는 그게 제일
잘 매입한 사례라고 생각을 합니다네
그래서 여러분들이 이렇게 보실 때
시기가 안 좋을 때 이렇게 이벤트가
생겨서 나오는 건물들이 있어요
시기가 안 좋아서 나왔거나 뭐이
중에는 이제 금리가 높아서 나온
사례도 있고 어떤 사례인지 정확히
말씀을 못 드리겠지만 세금을 못 내서
나온 사례도 있었어요 그리고 이렇게
저희가 사례를 보면은
갑자기 이제 상속세를 내야 되거나
아니면 기타 등등 이런 이슈 때문에
나오는 그런 이벤트 때문에 나오는
건물들이 있거든요 그런 건물들을
보면은 좀 되게 괜찮은 가격에 살 수
있는
그런 기회들이 있는 거 같습니다
간혹가다 이제 이런 매물들이 툭
나와요 그래서 여러분들이 이런 매물을
잡으려면 주변 매각 사례라든지 지금
그 주변의 분위기라든지 이런 걸
파악을 하고 계셔야 돼요 제가
항상 말씀드리지만 이런 매각 사례들을
좀 항상 보실 필요가 있어요
요런
시장에서
요런 시기에 이런 기회들이 오기
때문에 좀 제 말을 기억하셨다가 좀
이런 괜찮은 매물이 나왔을 때 좀
이렇게 빠른 결정을 하셔서 좀 이렇게
성공적인 투자를 하셨으면 좋겠습니다네
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 더 유익한 소식으로 다시
돌아오도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다